[Music]
here's everything you need to know about
the sexual harassment allegations made
against louis ck's on thursday the new
york times broken in-depth article Louie
CK is accused of sexual misconduct by
five women it details the alleged
incidents and for the first time names
named but rumors have been swirling for
years
Gawker first addressed rumblings of
misconduct in a 2012 blind item about an
unnamed comedian who forces female
comics to watch him masturbate the story
cites one incident which has now been
detailed in The Times article at the
Aspen Comedy Festival then in May 2015
Gawker claimed that Louis was their 2012
blind item subject the next month
comedian Jen Kirkman talked about an
unnamed male comic during her I seem fun
podcast revealing quote he's a known
perv this guy didn't rape me but he made
a certain difficult decision to go on
tour with him really hard in May 2016
Louise pal John Stuart deflected a
question about his friend during a live
taping of David Axelrod's podcast I'm
not that connected to that world so I do
apologize I don't know what you're
talking about but but no I can't really
I don't know and on June 13th 2016 Louie
addressed rumors for the first time
telling vulture that the Gawker items
weren't real later that month Roseanne
Barr called him out in an interview with
The Daily Beast quote it's louis c.k
locking the door and masturbating in
front of women comics and writers in
september louis refused to answer
questions about sexual misconduct rumors
telling the New York Times quote I'm not
going to answer that stuff because
they're rumors then on Thursday his I
love you daddy premiere was abruptly
cancelled just before the latest Times
article broke the studio tells ET quotes
the premiere is
cancelled there is no other statement
beyond that
[Music]
you
[Music]